ja dann geht es weiter jetzt bin ich mal
so ein bisschen hier ein bisschen Inhalt
und dann können wir in die Diskussion
übergehen ich möchte jetzt einfach mal
ein bisschen ja zurückblicken was wir
vor hatten sie erinnern sich werden
gesagt eine Handlung braucht Gründe und
Behandlung bezahlen Gründe sind die
Antwort auf die Frage aber nachdem warum
eine Handlung ich hatte dann so ein
bisschen frontiert gesagt die Antwort
auf eine bloß willkürliche Handlung wenn
man überhaupt eine bloßen natürlich hier
in diesem schlechtesten Handlungen eine
Handlung nennen möchte wäre darum ja
warum hast du das gemacht und dann sagt
ihm die Person darum und dann sind sie
genauso schlau wie davor und wissen sie
nämlich gar nichts sie wissen einfach
nur die Person hat es halt gemacht weil
sie es gemacht hat sie müssen dann
überlegen was würden Sie denn gerne
hören zu wollen irgendwas informatives
wissen ein bloßes darum auf die Frage
warum hast du das gemacht das hilft
überhaupt nichts das sind diese
Schlaufen dass Sie wissen die person A
hat Handlung K vollzogen das Wissens
hier wenn die Person sagt ich habe die
Handwerk vollzogen weil ich die haben
sie vollzogen habe oder weil ich sie
verstehen wollte
gut ja schön das hilft ihm nichts das
heißt was sie eigentlich wissen wollen
sind die Gründe sie wollen also
eigentlich eine Geschichte hören sie
wollen eine kurze Erzählung in der das
Wort weil ein paar mal vorkommt
das ist das sind die Gründe sie wollen
und nicht nur ein Grund in der Bibel
weil ein Grund ist ja auch weil ich es
einfach wollte ja oder ein großeres
grundlos sie wollen verschiedene Gründe
idealerweise wollen sie hören dass die
Person sagt ich habe mit da ein paar
Gedanken gemacht ich habe mir jetzt
selber überlegt und habe mich mit das
überlegt und nach einer gewissen
Überlegung bin ich zu diesem Schluss
gekommen Beispiel die Frage warum haben
sie Philosophie studiert und warum
studieren wenn sie nicht dass sie jetzt
fragen sie sagen darum dann weiß ich
nicht das heißt in der Regel werden sie
jeweils für sich als individuelle
Personen und das ist auch das Thema der
heutigen Sitzung werden sie ganz
individuelle Gründe haben die
dafür ursächlich sind dass sie
Philosophie studieren das ist von
Personen zu Personen völlig
verschiedenes macht ähnliche Gründe
geben aber die Gründe im Einzelnen die
können variieren und ist auch völlig in
Ordnung weil das ist ihre individuelle
Freiheit ihre Autonomie ihre selbst
bestimmen sich für ein Studienfach zu
entscheiden da jede verschiedenen es
gibt nicht die wahren Gründe für ein
Philosophiestudium es gibt verschiedene
Personen und verschiedene Personen haben
verschiedene Überzeugungen verschiedenen
Interessen und verschiedenen Hintergrund
und das ist alles mit des fließt alles
mit in die Handlung 1 sofern sie das
auch immer reflektieren
ja Handlung setzen Gründe voraus und
Gründe kann man sehr schön in einer
Geschichte erzählen eine einer kleinen
Erzählung die durchaus auch
biografischen
ins Leben ein und dann wenn sie das mir
erzählen waren anderen Person erzählen
dann wird die sagen okay ich kann das
verstehen dass das leuchtet mir an okay
ja gut ja es könnte sogar sein die
Person sagt nachdem sie das erzählt
haben das kann jetzt aber nicht nach
viel bei deinem ganzen anderen Begabung
ja du bist doch noch so sportlich ja
warum bist du nicht professioneller
Eiskunstläufer geboren ja auch völlig
okay auch diese Reaktion kann kommen und
die ist auch völlig berechtigt ja warum
weil die Person sie versteht wenn sie
erkennt ihren Interessen wenn Sie die
Gründe nennen das heißt wenn sie gründen
anführen für ihre Handlung oder ihre
Entscheidung heißt es nie dass eine
andere Person die Gründe auch gut finden
muss ja es ist so ist es in meinem Leben
aber die Person kann zumindest
dagegen argumentieren oder
Missverständnis anmelden und auch das
ist nur möglich bei Gründen wenn sie
sagen darum habe ich es gemacht dann
kann die Person gar nicht richtig mit
ihnen ins Gespräch kommen wenn sie
Gründe geben dann gehen sie auch in ein
Dialog dann öffnen Sie sich für andere
Personen und können mit dem anderen
Person auch eine rationale weisen auch
reden und auch diskutieren über ihre
Gründe und Entscheidung und Hand ja
jetzt kann man sich fragen worin
unterscheiden sich Gründe von klosachen
dann das ist auch eine spannende Frage
Ursachen sind ja auch irgendwie Gründe
oder irgendwie ja der Grund für etwas ja
und wenn jetzt der Blitz hier einschlägt
dann hat der Blitz auch einen Grund ja
und das Feuer hier was dann im
universitätsknode ausbrechen könntet hat
auch ein Grund nämlich den Blitz Ursache
also häufig versendet man Gründe und
Ursachen auch gleichbedeutend ja und das
hängt wieder davon ab wie eng und
zweiten an den grundweg befasst und
weitesten Sinne ist kann man eine
Ursache einzeln tun
warum brennt das Gebäude fragen Sie und
dann sagt Ihnen eine Person der
Hausmeisterin weil der Blitz
eingeschlagen hat das ist der Grund und
zwar ist okay ich verstehe den Grund
weil ich kann verstehen natürlich hatte
der Himmel oder die Wolke keinen guten
Grund oder überhaupt kein Grund das zu
tun ja weil er keine Handlung
Blitzeinschlag ist keine Hand das heißt
im engeren Sinne setzt wie gesagt Grund
voraus dass ich in der Handlung handelt
dass hier ein Subjekt im Hintergrund war
eine Person die Idealfall die sich
entschieden hat das zu tun
und da steht dann wieder das Thema
mentale verursachen die Rolle wir sind
darauf schon eingegangen ja also mentale
verursachen heißt Leute es gibt ein
Grund der dann am Ende kausal dazu führt
dass ich das ganze tun jetzt kann man
eine kleine
Diskussionsrunde machen weil ich schon
die ersten Meldungen sehe
ja also Gründe Ursachen das ist ein
spannendes Thema und inklinationen ist
auch etwas ja also etwas unkliniert und
etwas macht nicht geneigt es gebe einen
guten Grund dafür aber es gibt auch gute
Gründe dafür das heißt ich muss mich am
Ende immer auch noch mal entscheiden
kann und Gründe haben immer auch
irgendwas vorsichtiges wissen man muss
sich dann fragen sind notwendige Dinge
und ich glaube nicht das ist der Witz
des Grundes sie kennt sich auf dem
Begriff der Notwendigkeit also das ist
sein muss und gar nicht anders das würde
man bei Gründen wohl nie sagen oder kann
man sich mal überlegen können wir noch
einmal diskutieren wenn sie jetzt sich
entschieden haben für Philosophie dann
werden Sie bestimmt auch noch eine
andere mögliche Wahl gehabt haben Grund
von anderes Fach ich kenne nur ganz
wenige Personen die sagen ich musste
Philosophie studieren und selbst dann
würden wir sagen eine andere Person das
mussten sie nicht niemand hat sie
gezwungen sie haben sich selbst und wenn
jemand sagt aber ich musste es wirklich
dann kann man wirklich in Frage stellen
ob das freie Handlung war also Freiheit
schließt Notwendigkeit aus und häufig
verwendet man auch müssen das Wort
müssen in einem Sinn der nicht
Notwendigkeit bedeutet strenge
Notwendigkeit ja zum Beispiel kann man
so müssen verstehen dass man sagt ich
habe es so gewollt ja das ist ein Motive
Leidenschaft in mir wobei Leidenschaft
dann wird es schon wieder fast jetzt
passt in Richtung Notwendigkeit aber im
allgemeinen Sprachgebraucht ich stehe da
voll dahinter ja ich kann mich total mit
identifizieren Identifikation ist auch
ein ganz Punkt ja so werden sie das in
der Regel sagen und dann werden sie
natürlich einräumen natürlich hätte ich
auch was anderes studieren können aber
es gab eben die und die Gründe und die
haben dazu geführt also immer noch ihre
Befreiung also sie sind nicht getrieben
worden Philosophie zu studieren sind
identifizieren sich mit ihren Wunsch das
zu tun jetzt können wir mal hier
weitergehen und noch mal diese Frage bin
ich noch mal kurz dran aufgreifen also
gibt es willkürliche Gründe also
nicht wirklich reflektiert das sind so
bloß die Liebe geben schlechten Sinne
gegründe darüber haben wir gesprochen
der Münzwurf ja also das scheint
irgendwie zu unserem Begriff das
Handelns entgegen zu stehen da ist
Philipp kein Identifikation statt ja
willkürlichen können Sie immer eine
Münze
wenn es mir völlig egal ist und Kopf
oder Zahl aus und ich davon noch
irgendwie ein Studienfach Studium
abhängig machen dann kann man das nicht
wirklich in guten Kunden ja sei denn man
wollte eben willkürlich haben das kann
natürlich auch machen ich will
willkürlich handeln und dann ist es okay
ja aber wer will denn willkürlich in
diesem schlechten zu mir haben
ja es kann ja sein man 50/50 ja man ist
genau unisch Philosophie oder Sport
50-50 ja dann werfe ich die Münzen okay
ja dann müsste man darüber entscheiden
wie es dann aussieht Identifikation
identifizieren eigentlich möchte man
doch dass man sich wirklich eindeutig
identifiziert jetzt möchte ich noch eben
ein Punkt hier noch ins Gespräch bringen
nämlich häufig spricht man von
subjektiven objektiven Gründen ja das
möchte ich ein bisschen problematisieren
gibt es einen Unterschied zwischen bloß
subjektiven Gründen Objektiv wir kommen
darauf nach häufig ist damit gemeint
subjektive Gründe sind halt Gründe die
unsere individuellen Vorlieben betreffen
jeder hat andere Gründe
für seine Handlung aber es gibt noch
objektive und es sind heute im moralisch
gute und moralisch zu machen also ich
tue etwas weil ich das tun soll ja weil
das dass die Moral vorgibt
zu sprechen kommt das Befehl das was ich
tun das ist objektiven Gründe da gibt es
gar keine Wahl und keine Entscheidung
dafür oder dagegen das muss getan werden
selbst wenn das getan werden soll muss
ich doch nicht immer noch entscheiden
das zu tun also gibt es subjektive
Gründe für objektive Gründe mache ich
mir ein objektiven Grund zum reinigenden
Grund aber da ist doch da irgendwie auch
individuelle Entscheidung beteiligt
das heißt ob ich mich für das moralisch
gebotenentscheid oder nicht das sind
doch wieder von meiner Entscheidung und
ist dann am Ende wenn ich moralisch
handelt ist es dann objektiver Grund
oder ein subjektive Probleme mit der
Subjekt Zukunft objektiven Grund zu
wählen
objektiven Grund meine Handlung
handlungswirksam werden aber sie sehen
wie diese Unterscheidung zwischen
subjektiven objektiven Gründen ist nicht
so ganz klar wir kommen da drauf heute
ist es jetzt nur ein Vorblick ist noch
gar nicht die eigentlich Diskussion ich
möchte nur ein überblicken geben über
die ganzen Themen wir gehen dann
wirklich in den Detail wirklich drauf
noch ein ja die nächste Sitzung wird
sich dann mit dem Thema befassen was ist
praktische Vernunft
praktische Vernunft da können wir jetzt
auch mal eine ganz kurze
kurze diskussionspause machen weil mich
würde interessieren was sie dazu nein
ja und jetzt wollen wir uns mal mit
dieser praktischen Luft noch ein
bisschen genau befassen also ich habe
schon so ein bisschen was gesagt häufig
sagt man das Vermögen Gründe für handelt
vorzubringen auch die könnte abzuwehren
und auch zu verstehen
man muss ja auch die Grünen eine andere
Person verstehen können für die Handlung
und jetzt haben wir dieses diesen Punkt
schon diskutiert warum unterscheidet
sich moralische bewusst instrumenteller
praktisches
die man kann jedes beliebige Ziel
vorgesetzt bekommen selbst etwas
Unmoralisches ich möchte diese Person
töten und dann sagt mir sozusagen ich
rede jetzt die von der Person als ob den
Subjekt Zeit das ist natürlich auch dann
sagt mir die Vernunft eigentlich nicht
reparieren gar nichts weil sie keine
Subjekt ist ja aber so kann man
landläufig reden dann sagt mir die
Vernunft okay wenn du das tun möchtest
dann machen das mache ich das machen das
war eine Person ist es natürlich was
unmoralisches und das widerspricht dem
kategorischen Imperativ
nach Kant jetzt möchte ich noch auf was
ganz anderes interessantes angenehm ich
habe wie gesagt praktische Philosophie
betrifft unser Handeln im weitesten
Sinne aus philosophischer Perspektive
und wir haben jetzt immer wenn wir von
Handlungen gesprochen hatten von
irgendwas handfester gesprochen ja also
ein Messer die habe ich einen Mörder
gesprochen oder eine Mörderin und die
irgendwie unschuldiges Opfer verfolgt
und dann ist es natürlich der Parade von
einer anderen Erde da ist jemand der
rennt und hat irgendwie noch was in der
Hand ein Werkzeug und insofern häufig
dann handeln verstanden also handeln vom
von der Hand ja jetzt gibt es aber
natürlich auch Handlung und das ist
wieder Philosophie erst in 20
Jahrhundert aufgefallen ist so richtig
dass wir auch mit der Sprache was tun
können das sind sogenannte sprachantwort
nicht mit uns nur mit unseren Händen
auch mit unserer Sprache von einem
philosophenplanungsfond der hat ein Buch
geschrieben haute die things with words
wie können wir Dinge tun mit Wörtern und
zwar ist es aus dem Jahr 1955 man er
spricht von sogenannten sprechpart
natürlich kann man sagen auch sprechen
könnte Handeln sein
darüber kann man sich jetzt streiten
Wort auszusprechen und Satz zu sprechen
ist das jetzt kommunizieren ist das
Handeln
das meint er gar nicht so er meint
besondere spricht Akte die wir sprachen
funktionieren und wer von ihnen schon
Linguistik hatte kennt die
Unterscheidung zwischen Semantik und
Pragmatik ja es geht um die pragmat
nicht um die Bedeutung von Wörtern
sondern um das was mir mit diesen
Wörtern mit der Sprache tun und solche
sprechpakte sind zum Beispiel wir fehlen
Taufe und ver wenn ich etwas einer
Person Befehle dann kann ich schon sagen
dass ich dadurch handelt weil ich führe
etwas in Bewegung ich ja kann etwas
vornehmen ich folge Gründen Taufen
genauso viel mit nehme ich hiermit
ernenne ich dich
auch Benennungen ritterschläge ja das
sind performative Sprechakte ja wenn die
Queen sagt die mit schlage ich dich zum
Ritter meistens muss ich ja noch ein
Schwert nehmen so ein ganz langes und
können diesen Menschen auf die Schulter
tippen zweimal dreimal keine Ahnung da
kommt da häufig noch was anderes dazu
aber häufig wird das auch in diese
diesen Sprechakt
Gift im einbezogen ja also hiermit bzw
übergeben die eine Rolle
genauso versprechen ich verspreche dir
das zu tun
versprechen wie kann häufig auch
einzigste aufgefasst werden mit dem wir
auch noch diese Verpflichtung eingeht
wir machen uns da irgendwie abhängig ich
gebe ein Versprechen und dann muss ich
aber auch behalten weil sonst sagt die
Person du hast es mir versprochen und du
hast nicht dran gehalten und es kann
sogar auch juristisch dann manchmal
problematisch werden wenn ich das
Versprechen unterzeugen die
sehen also man kann mit Worten sehr viel
tun und nicht nur Dinge beschreiben und
ausdrücken und man kann auch wirklich
Verpflichtung eingehen man kann mit
Worten ganz viel tun ja du kannst
natürlich auch andere Menschen verletzen
geworden und so weiter und so fort
darauf hat man leider viel zu wenig
geachtet weil das immer so alltäglichen
tun wir doch die ganze Zeit ja dann kann
man gehen aber wirklich tun ist was
anderes aber es gibt eben auch eine
Dimension der Sprache die
beinhaltet dass sie damit auch
Handlungen vollziehen müssen die
sogenannten Sprechakte und da wollen wir
uns auch in dieser Sitzung ganz
ausführlich mit befassen und im
Einzelnen schon was für Typen von
sprechtakten gibt es ja dann gehört auch
zu dieser
vorlesungssitzung die sogenannte Theorie
des kommunikativen Handelns für Jürgen
habermaus Hans vielleicht schon mal
gehört ja das ging auch so ein bisschen
diese Richtung also wir
kommunizieren und indem wir
kommunizieren handeln wir ja er spricht
auch von einer besonderen Vernunft die
da im Spiel ist wenn wir durch
Kommunikation handelt es geht auch um
eine
Gesellschaftstheorie eine politische
Philosophie die habe massiv entwickelt
die immer auf diesen Sprechakten auf was
das soll auch eine Vorlesung sozusagen
dann ein mich persönlich sehr
interessierendes Thema werden wir uns
mit moralischen Gefühlen und Emotionen
befassen dann hier kann man jetzt mal
treffen drüber diskutieren was der
Unterschied zwischen Gefühlen und
Emotionen ist
ja moralisches Gefühl und Emotionen
inwiefern sind sie mögliche Gründe
Verhandlungen welche Rolle spielen
Gefühle und Emotionen von vorhanden wir
haben noch ein paar andere Phänomen
Stimmungen Aspekten wir müssen diese
Verhältnisse Phänomene müssen wir klären
man vertritt manchmal die Auffassung das
Emotionen Gründe für Handeln sein können
zum Beispiel wenn es um moralische
Motivation geht darauf kommen wir gleich
noch zu sprechen welche Rolle spielen
Gefühle und Emotionen von seinem
moralisches Handeln
kann ich aus Achtung aus Achtung vor der
Würde eines Person ins achtungsgefüge
gehen auch immer einen Krankheit wir
haben dieses Gefühl besonders
hervorgerufen das ist einfach Emotionen
sie ist trotzdem noch Kant ein Grund und
das betrifft jetzt das nächste Thema
moralische Motivation auch Motivation
was treibt uns unseren Handlungen ja wir
mögen verschiedene Wünsche haben
vielleicht auch Gründe die für etwas
sprechen aber das sind Gründe als solche
schon handlungswirksam also sind sie
hinreichend dafür dass wir dann auch
dadurch motiviert werden also anders
gefragt können Gründe motivieren ja
Kollegen können Sie mal was nicht
überlegen da gibt es ein Grund und ist
der Grund dasselbe was sie dann zu
handeln bringt oder muss dann auch
Emotionen dazu kommen
emotional getönter willenskaustritt weil
darüber müssen wir diskutieren was kann
denn soll uns zum moralischen Handlungen
motivieren ja
dürfen Gefühle Emotionen daran beteiligt
sein wenn es unmoralisch Handeln geht
oder haben die da gar nichts zu suchen
weil man sagen könnte sobald uns
Emotionen mit dem Spiel kommt Emotionen
haben und gehört zum 16 individuell dann
hat es nicht sein Objektivität gibt es
nur noch Subjektivität jeder hat andere
Emotionen jeder hat andere
Stimmungslagen darauf können wir keine
Moral Gründen ja
die Frage welche Rolle spielen Vernunft
und Gefühle und Emotionen bei Motivation
von moralischen
da gibt es ein ganz spannende Debatte ja
manche sagen ja Gefühle sollen wir Rolle
spielen oder Emotionen und da gibt es an
Diskussionen zum Beispiel darüber ob
jetzt das Mitleid die geeignete
moralische Motivation ist
bleibt oder Menschenliebe Liebe oder
Achtung Respekt darüber kann man
wirklich auch treffen diskutieren
welches dieser welche dieser emotionalen
Zustände
am besten geeignet ist um ja uns zu
moralischen Handeln zu bewegen und
darüber würde ich gerne auch kurz mit
ihm diskutieren
ja moralische Motivation ist ein
wichtiges Thema wie wir gesehen haben
und wir gehen jetzt gerade mal weiter
praktische Normativität möchte ich damit
erwähnen und wir sind schon immer wieder
drauf gekommen hier geht es um das
sollen also Normativität ist die Norm
das heißt geboten ist das woran wir uns
orientieren sollen ihr Maßstab handeln
von einem Maßstab es gibt verschiedene
Maßstäbe zum Beispiel sind wir
instrumentellen
zugrunde liegen ist hängt immer davon ab
was von Maßstäbe gebe ich dir Handel
braucht immer Regeln Orientierung die
verschiedenen Arten von Normativität im
höchsten Sinne ist die Normativität
moralische Normativität da geht es um
das gute Hand ja nicht um das
schnelladresse reiht das ist vielleicht
auch eine Normalität der bringt die
beste Leistung aber die moralische
Normativität interessiert sich nicht so
viel um Quantität
das ist moralisch
vor diesem Hintergrund ist wie so ein
Horizont vor dem sich auch unser Handeln
abspielt woran können wir die Moralität
unsere Handlung Motivation bemessen also
nicht die Handlungen können moralisch
sein sind auch unsere Motive unsere
Gründe können moralisch ungeranntlich
sein ich kann böse oder schlechte
Absichten hegen ja das und wie können
wir das objektiv beurteilen was jetzt
moralisch tut oder böse ist und Handlung
oder uns zum Motiven und wie können wir
das erkennen wie können wir überhaupt
moralische Normativität begründen wie
können wir absolut festlegen was
moralisch gut und was und war nicht böse
ist ja geht es um die nutzen was zum
größten Nutzen bringt ist ein normalen
Studie oder geht es hier um eine Art von
logischer Widerspruchsfreiheit zu
spricht und man kann hier macht es fast
schon mathematisch ja wie verhalten sich
auch deskriptive sein also deskript
heißt beschreibend was ist das dann ist
schon so das ist das richtig ich war
noch normative Formen was soll so sein
zueinander gibt es ja Übergang von
seinem Funktionen oder sind es zwei
unabhängige Welten und wie verhalten
sich naturalistische Prädikate die
angenehm angenehm nützlich es fühlt sich
gut an das ist naturalistisches trifft
unsere Natur zu Prädikaten normativ für
die Karten gut können wir gut dieses
Wort gut erklären durch eine Zunge von
anderen naturalistischen Prädikaten die
angenehm nützlich schön oder so weiter
lässt sich das darüber bestimmen viele
Philosophen sagen nein da gibt es eine
absolute Kluft zwischen dem sein und den
Song wir können das sollen das normative
nicht über naturalistische Prädikate die
angenehm erklären das Gute lässt sich
nicht über angenehm und so weiter wir
werden das geht über das Los angelegen
hinaus das ist eigentlich gar nicht
wirklich begrifflich definierbar das
Gute ist irgendwie
Assistent sagen hat das beschreiben alle
deskriptiven
Definitionsversuchen weil es einfach ein
Norm ist
ja politische Gerechtigkeit wenn zu
einem Handel geben müssen natürlich auch
kollektives Handeln mit behandeln im
größeren Kontexten ja wie kann das
Zusammenleben vernünftige Individuen so
durchgesetzt und Verträge geregelt
werden dass alle die gleichen Rechte und
Pflichten haben
kollektive Regel und Gerechtigkeit was
ist überhaupt Gerechtigkeit und was
nicht persönlich interessiert wie können
wir durch die Richtigkeit
neidgefühlen vermeiden weil ich glaube
dass der Neid eine ganz große Rolle
spielt in der Gesellschaft und
Gerechtigkeit muss immer dafür sorgen
dass Leid kein Platz hat interessiert
mich persönlich gerade auch anders
moralisch Studium besteht das Gute im
allgemeinen wir haben uns schon darüber
Gedanken gemacht wie sich gut und
angenehm zueinander verhalten was sind
Werte die verhalten sich Werte zu
gründen ja worin besteht das moralisch
gut wir können wir Werte erkennen wie
können wir Werte begründen was ist
überhaupt ein Wert genauso das moralisch
böse worin besteht das böse und schlecht
im allgemeinen worin das moralisch böse
wie verhält sich das sympathisch böse
zum moralisch guten ist es nur das
Gegenteil davon oder ist es irgendwas
anderes das ist nur ein Defizit ist es
nur noch nicht perfekt gut ein Mangel
anbieten oder ist das gegen gute
böse gegen macht und da gibt es ganz
verschiedene Auffassung die wir auch
behandeln wollen dann moralische
zurechnungbarkeit welche Bedingungen
müssen gegeben sein damit wir für eine
Handlung verantwortlich sind
und zwar müssen wir uns stellen wie
können individuelle und kollektive
Personen für Handeln verantwortlich sein
auch noch ein spannendes Thema ist
moralisches Selbsttäuschung oder
praktische Selbsttäuschung wie kommen
wir dazu dass wir uns selbst über unsere
Gründe und Motive täuschen das passiert
nämlich sehr häufig häufiger als wir
denken inwiefern täuschen wir uns um
unsere praktischen Gründe was sind die
Gründe für unsere praktisch oder
moralische Selbsttäuschung inwiefern
sind wir auch verantwortlich für unsere
Selbsttäuschung also viele Philosophen
sagen wir sind selbst schuld für unseren
Irrtum häufig würde man ja sagen wird
schon wieder nicht und die Unternehmen
passiert einfach so ja aber viele
Philosophen haben gesagt und Philosophen
nein wir sind selbst schuld für irrtum
bei den Irrtum nur dann stattfinden kann
wenn wir
uns etwas überlebt haben wenn wir etwas
gedacht haben und etwas wollten wo auch
Wünsche beteiligt war etwas abgezielt
haben und uns aber eigentlich selbst
belügt haben auch so dass sie selbst
möge ich mitwirken zusammen also wie
sind wir für unsere Selbstlüge
verantwortlich Willensschwäche ist ein
Phänomen wenn ihr Wille nicht einhalten
sie bildet werden kann
diskutiert wenn Sie den Willen nicht
einheitlich Formen können wie kommt es
dass obwohl wir etwas wollen manchmal
nicht zum Handeln gelangen
dann ein ganz wichtiger Begriff der
Freiheitsbegriff wir müssen
unterscheiden Handlungsfreiheit was wir
können gleich noch darüber diskutieren
Handlungsfreiheit was das ist aber weil
wir nicht mehr so viel Zeit haben sage
ich jetzt einfach mal kurz handlungsfrei
ist einfach die Freiheit tun zu können
was man will
tun zu können was man will
und jetzt gibt es noch die
Willensfreiheit und die muss man davon
wir müssen einen Gewinn sein entstehen
die die heilen ist nicht die Freiheit
tun zu können was man will sondern die
Freiheit etwas Bestimmtes wollen zu
können wie können Sie etwas Bestimmtes
wollen können Sie sich aussuchen was sie
wollen wollen das ist doch ein bisschen
paradox weil wenn sie etwas wollen dann
wollen sie es doch schon diese sollen
wir wollen wir wollen noch wollen wollen
ist es nicht schon genug wenn Sie einen
Willen haben dann ist doch alles okay
warum sollen sie sich noch mal zu ihren
Willen Verhalten
wozu das ist dann Bildungsfreiheit ich
habe es falsch hingeschrieben und
darüber muss man sprechen da würde ich
gerne auch noch mal ganz kurz Ihre
Meinung dazu wissen was der Unterschied
ist zwischen handlungsfrei und
willenseiten
so und jetzt müssen wir so langsam zum
Schluss kommen und ich habe noch was
richtig vor
also wir wollen nämlich jetzt am Schluss
noch ein auszugeben über
praktische Philosophie in Zeiten
Digitalisierung wie viel können wir auch
ein virtuell handeln und mit der Wertung
wer von ihnen hat metaversums Brillen
gibt es jemand niemand habe ich mir
gedacht von Meta nicht Geld das ist noch
gar nicht so wirklich in und vielleicht
ist es auch gar nicht die mögliche Idee
vom wetterversen sind Brille zu machen
vielleicht besteht dann andere mehr so
teuer genau ja was sind die Bedingungen
für virtuelles Handeln ist auch eine
Stunde Fahrt können wir virtuell handeln
also nicht physisch bin wie können wir
virtuelles Handeln bewerten können
Roboter Handeln darauf haben wir das
letzte mal darüber gesprochen und jetzt
möchte ich zum Schluss noch auf die
individuelle Person
es gibt nämlich ganz verschiedene
Möglichkeiten Personen zu bestimmen
an prominentesten das haben wir schon
gehört ist die These dass wir
selbstbewusste gewesen sind also
Selbstbewusstsein für unsere
Personalität entscheidend
hat eine solche Theorie entwickelt
und
erlebt im 17 Jahrhundert und er sagt wir
müssen zwischen drei Arten von Identität
unterscheiden und identitätsprinzipien
es gibt Dinge Substanzen wie zum
Beispiel hier diese Fernbedienung wir
haben Identität und er sagt wenn ich nur
ein kleines Teilchen davon wegnehmen
dann ist es eigentlich mit der selben
Team also numerisch gesehen von der
Anzahl obwohl ich natürlich dasselbe
machen kann aber streng genommen wenn
ich mein kleines Teilchen mitnehme die
Identität ändert sich permanent hören
weil hier permanent Teile weggenommen
werden dann haben wir noch die Identität
des Menschen
und entscheidend ist wir müssen davon
noch unterscheiden die Identität der
Person also Menschen Person haben nicht
diese Identitätsprinzip
so sah der gute Mann aus und
ja er sagt jetzt meine Meinung nach
bezieht sich dieses Wort Personen das
bedeutet ein verständiges Wesen das
wünscht und Überlegung besitzt und sich
selbst als selbst betrachten kann das
ist seine Definition der Person
und die Ponte ist jetzt soweit nun
dieses Bewusstsein der Person rückwärts
auf Vergangenheit haben oder Gedanken
ausgedehnt werden kann soweit reicht
Identität Depression also sie sind nur
so lange existent wie sie sich zurück
erinnern können an Vergangenheit zu
stehen ihr Selbstbewusstsein definiert
sie in ihrer Identität
Erinnerungen das woran ich mich nicht
erinnern kann das bin ich
das ist natürlich ein bisschen
problematisch denken Sie an Ihre
Kindheiten zu machen
jetzt bringt ja interessantes Beispiel
nehmen wir an die Seele eines Fürsten
die das Bewusstsein des vergangenen
Lebens das Fürchten mit sich führt dreht
in den Körper eines Schusters einen
anderen Menschen
sobald dessen eigenes Leben verlassen
Seelen tauscht zum Beispiel jeder sieht
ein dass der Schuster dann dieselbe
Person sein würde wie der Fluss und nur
für dessen Tagen verantwortlich
Bewusstsein in der Beschreibung wenn
also die Seele das Selbstbewusstsein die
Erinnerung das Gedächtnis des Fürsten in
den organischen lebendigen Körper eines
Schusters hineintreten würde dann würde
der schusterkörper der lebendige
schusterkörper bei all das
verantwortlich sein
was der Fürst getan hat obwohl der
schusterkörper keine einzige Tat
wirklich organisch begangen hat die der
Fürst begangen hat wir diskutieren das
gleiche natürlich muss jetzt leider
weitergehen das müssen Sie mir
vorstellen ja also das legt seinen
Personen Theorie nahe das so was möglich
ist ist natürlich schwer vorstellbar
dass du was wirklich möglich ist ist
aber in Gedankenexperiment ja und jetzt
geht er weiterhin sagt das sieht jeder
das sein kleiner Finger solange er von
diesen Bewusstsein erfasst wird ebenso
ein Teil seines Selbst ausmacht wie das
was am allerersten dazu gehört sollte
bei einer Abtrennung dieses Gliedes
dieses kleinen Fingers das Bewusstsein
im folgen
und aus dem übrigen Körper verschwinden
so wird offenbar der kleine Finger die
Person dieselbe Person sein das selbst
würde mit dem übrigen Teil des Körpers
nicht zu tun haben also sehen wir ein
kleiner Finger jetzt in meinem
Bewusstsein dann wäre meine persönliche
da wurde Selbstbewusstsein ist da wo die
Erinnerung ist da ist die Person und die
kann das Bewusstsein die Erinnerung kann
sich in ganz verschiedenen Dingen und
Organismen ja
niederlassen sozusagen ja und das ist
natürlich eine spannende these es gibt
noch eine andere Philosophen der ist
jetzt ein bisschen neuer der geht noch
weiß ich nicht so alt und der hat eine
These übertrieben die dem
entgegengesetzt ist das Human animals
Personal identity without sie können es
schon ahnungslos
wir sind Tiere das heißt biologische
Organismen
diese These lautet nicht dass unser
Körper Tiere sein was muss hinten
abgestritten wird ich will nicht
behaupten dass alle Tiere Personen sind
womöglich gibt es einen Gott oder Ihnen
vielleicht gibt es auch maßmenschen die
Personen sind aber keine Tiere ich
behaupte ebenfalls nicht dass alle Tiere
Personen sind Schnecken zum Beispiel
sind vermutlich keine Person ich
behaupte lediglich dass manche Tiere
Personen sind und zwar Normalfall
Menschen
diese Behauptung hat heute im Namen
animalismus also was wir sind
bedeutet nach Olson das dass wir
wesentlich Tiere sind wir sind keine
Personen sondern wir sind wesentlich
menschliche Tiere die manchmal Personen
sind wenn sie gewisse Eigenschaften mit
sich bringt aber auch manchmal nicht und
das ist die These des animalismus weil
die ist natürlich
entgegengesetzt und es gibt noch eine
Tees und Baker ist die
konstruktionsthese und sie sagt calling
to animal Lesen der ist nur unterlagical
distinction between
findet
also nach den animatismus gibt es
zwischen uns Menschen und Würmern keinen
essentiellen und wir sind ein dasselbe
von Identitätsprinzip wie Würmer
stimmt das wirklich
sind wirklich alles was anderes der
gesagt wir sind Personen wesentlich und
keine Tiere gegen den animals so und
jetzt möchte ich noch mal zum Schluss
mit ihm eine Abstimmung machen sind wir
im Grunde Tiere Person